the U.S has returned 266 ancient
artifacts to Italy police in Rome
discovered the items had been looted and
sold by an international network of
smugglers in the late 1990s Antiquities
up to 3 000 years old were among the
whole Italy said some of the pieces are
worth tens of millions of Euros this is
the latest repatriation of ancient
artifacts from the U.S to Rome in
January archaeological artifacts valued
more than 18 million euros were returned
from New York well let's get more on
this now we're joined by Christopher
Marinello he's the CEO of art recovery
International he hasn't worked on this
specific case but frequently works with
Italian and other Authorities on the
return of stolen cultural heritage he's
in London and he's joining us live thank
you very much for your time this is a
very confusing Trail will there be a
search for who stole this art and
artifacts in the 1990s possibly even
earlier than that
well unfortunately the people who
actually looted the tombs in Italy will
probably never be located but what
happened is there was a British dealer
named Robin symes a notorious dealer who
was buying from these so-called
tombaroli or tomb Raiders in Italy and
then moving them on to some very
important collections
where is Robert symes Lao out of
curiosity
well interestingly he was never arrested
for smuggling Antiquities the only time
he was arrested was for contempt of
court uh but his uh former Gallery is
now in the administration in Europe and
in the UK in bankruptcy uh and tied up
in the courts in both countries okay
this is your area of great expertise
just how difficult is it to find the
culprits of these things
well it's extremely difficult to find
the individuals that actually did the
digging but what Italy has
done is they have
made a database of criminals who were
handling these looted objects and then
they are very uh wisely working with U.S
and other authorities to help enforce
their export laws and in this way
the Italian uh cultural heritage police
are able to recover objects that are in
museums or in very important collections
throughout the world including the US
you've answered my uh what was going to
be my next question which is why has
Italy done such a great job of
recovering looted objects why is it that
Italy can do these things that other
countries can't or don't is it the is it
that they have the will to the resources
but it really comes down to financing
they uh have put a priority on
recovering their cultural heritage Italy
is an incredible Source country for
Antiquities and they put a great deal of
interest and financing into this project
and any country could do so I mean of
course I mean there's a lot of things in
Italy that do not see this type of
financing but uh this is important to
Italy and this is where they put the
money and and it's working it's it's had
phenomenal success okay these artifacts
were stolen around the 1990s as were
mentioned just how big is the market for
stolen artifacts now
um it's it's it's huge it always has
been a problem there have always been
people who are digging uh and stealing
things from archaeological sites and
they get virtually nothing sometimes
just enough to eat it's the middlemen
it's the people who know what these
objects are and then move them to
Western markets where people pay big
money without checking the provenance of
these objects and by provenance I mean a
complete history an analysis of where
these objects came from okay and it's
astounding to me that people will pay
millions and millions of dollars in
euros for these objects another checking
where they came from another thing that
I find astounding that you've just
mentioned is that people are able to
access what what are sensitive what must
be sensitive archaeological sites in
order to loot from them how are they
able to do that
well if you knew the Topography of Italy
these sites are all over everywhere even
when when Rome was digging their Subway
they ran into uh incredible Roman ruins
so it's it's almost impossible to police
every single site in Italy as it is
impossible to Police Every site in in
the world all right Mr Marinello it's
great to get your expertise on the
subject we really appreciate it that is
Christopher Marinello the CEO of art
recovery International live in London
thank you
fireplace